i duly declare imran nazir ahmed khan
elected as the member of parliament for
the wakefield parliamentary constitution
imran ahmed khan was elected in 2019 as
wakefield's first conservative mp for 89
years with a majority of just 3358
now the 48 year old has been found
guilty by a jury at southwark crown
court of sexually assaulting a 15 year
old boy 14 years ago
the court heard his victim complained to
the conservative party about the assault
before the election and that he said he
wasn't taken very seriously
the jury was told mr khan forced the
teenager to drink gin pushed him onto a
bed and asked him to watch pornography
before touching his feet and legs the
victim then fled
the conservative party has acted swiftly
without waiting to find out what
sentence mr khan will receive they have
expelled him from the party with
immediate effect
what happens next is not clear if he's
given more than a year in prison mr khan
would be disqualified as an mp a shorter
jail term would lead to a recall
petition where constituents could force
him out
on the streets of wakefield there are
plenty of voters who want him to go if
somebody's
not upholding what the law says
then how can they
function and represent
people properly no no no no it shouldn't
be there somebody
he shouldn't be your mp no no absolutely
not
it's a call repeated by labour in a
brief statement they said imran ahmed
khan should immediately resign so a
by-election can take place and the
people of wakefield can get the
representation they deserve
boris johnson is keen to be photographed
with his red wall mps but a by-election
in a red wall constituency with a narrow
majority would be keenly fought i
promise
the judge will pass sentence later he
warned mr khan he could be sent to jail
gerard sky news wakefield